this is such a dream come true Kourtney
Kardashian is home home on the range
the reality star hit up Instagram on
Monday to share tons of pics from her
getaway to Lake Powell in Utah like this
one yep that's the mom of three standing
on some Red Rocks barefoot looking chic
AF in a coordinating rust-colored
two-piece she captioned the shot quote
escaped to the desert complete with a
cactus camel and Sun emoji obviously the
41 year old also shared a series of pics
with her two youngest kiddos
seven-year-old Penelope and
five-year-old rein horseback riding
alongside the caption Western fun right
I love it
well it gets even better quartz shared
some more from the family getaway in her
stories including a Zen boat ride out on
the lake
some camp side marshmallow roasting and
more from that horseback ride and get
this it appears her ex Scott Disick was
there too
he shared several pics dated from the
weekend to his insta stories including
this sweet daddy-daughter pic with
Penelope writing my little girl is just
too pretty and this pic by the pool I
think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day earlier this month et learned
Scott previously checked himself into a
Colorado rehab at the time a source told
et both Kourt and his current girlfriend
Sophia Ricci influenced his decision to
seek help for substance abuse issues at
the end of the day Scott needs to be
cleaned to be around his children and
family and that's everyone's main focus
right now Scott's sobriety and the kids
having a healthy father but this wasn't
Scott's first time seeking help if I
didn't have those kids I would kill
myself
but I have them and I'm gonna be here
and I'm gonna make it right for them you
know in 2015 he entered a rehab facility
in Malibu for a month before checking
out marking his fourth known attempt
that year it was definitely a process
during a 2016 episode of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians Kim and Chloe talked
about Scott going to rehab he wants to
really get it together and wants to go
to rehab for a long time and I think
that it all sounds amazing I just hope
that he sticks with it he's like I'm
eight days sober and I just want to you
know really get it together this time
like for my kids that's good and in a
super teaser for the upcoming episodes
of the families hit reality show Scott
opened up about how he's handling
quarantine he was with Scott last year
he opened up about what matters most
through the ups and downs I mean there's
so many different things that could pull
you in different directions and you
could look online and Instagram social
meeting all these things but at the end
of the day I mean you just want to be
happy you want to be content you want to
be comfortable
[Music]